kara swisher is one of the most powerful
tech journalists in the united states
she
is an opinion writer for the new york
times she hosts two wonderful podcasts
sway and pivot i highly can recommend
them
at this point and after all she's the
model of three cara thank you so much
for making time again for deutsche
berlin fantastic hi eunice how you doing
good great great seeing you cara so tell
me what is so spectacular about the
information francis hogan the facebook
whistle plower a blower has been leaking
well one of the things is a lot of
people have been talking about these
issues around facebook for a long time
right these issues around teens around
misinformation around sort of
worldwide this has been an issue but
she's bringing documents internal
documents where facebook with that
facebook executives are looking at to
make determinations and she also brought
brought a point of view saying that lots
of people on facebook look at these
these internal documents and are very
worried and want facebook executives to
do something different than the choices
they're making so i think one of the
things that's interesting is that it's
just the tip of the iceberg of
information from inside this company
that needs to come out so we understand
how facebook works and what impact it
has and there's no better information
than the information from from
internally that they're measuring
themselves and so that was great the
other thing is she's incredibly
articulate in talking about things that
we all have talked about i have talked
about this for years written about it
for years but when someone's an insider
they bring their receipts and they
actually explain it to the general
public in a smart way i think it has an
impact on on how people feel about
facebook and especially the legislators
who were listening and you saw they were
they they were paying rap attention to
it
so cara that we maybe we can break it up
a little bit so one thing she's talking
about really about the harm
[Music]
caused by instagram space specifically
for
uh teens and uh when i understand it
right it's basically all coming down to
algorithms maybe you can explain a
little bit how that works and why that
is so dangerous well one of the things
is look no matter how you have it if you
had if you knew about phone calls that
teens you're making a lot of stuff was
was people didn't see they didn't know
the parties they weren't invited to they
didn't know the friendships they weren't
part of um and and they also didn't get
constant pictures of people who are
prettier and slimmer and living better
lives than them and so no matter how you
slice this particular medium is is a lot
about fomo which is you know i wish i
was there i'm not and it makes you feel
bad about yourself and so it eats at
your self-esteem there's been this has
been happened in the past this is just
turbocharged and amplified and so one of
the things it does and i think uh
senator blumenthal showed this is they
created a fake account and the minute of
a teen who said they had eating disorder
and the minute the teen that this was up
they started getting really negative
stuff around food and around uh body
image and things like that and so it
wasn't helping this fake person this
fake teen girl um it was hurting her so
if you're if you get an inundation of
information that's not good for you
eventually it eats at your self-esteem
and this would is what some of the
statistics shows but also some of the
statistics show that people do well have
good well-being on it and so great let's
have all the information and then let's
have real researchers look at it and
then we can talk about it and that's the
one thing facebook is making all the
decisions itself and honestly they're
not the people that should be making
these decisions or at least determining
what their data which they take took
from us is saying about us we should
have independent people evaluating it
and then helping facebook do a better
job at a service how could this be done
what should be done well um hold on
i'm sorry um they would need to pass a
law i think requiring facebook to share
research it's been a real rocky road for
researchers and a number of them spoken
out this past week about the lack of uh
insight into what's happening inside of
facebook now facebook has done a lot of
research let's be clear most companies
don't do this much research and and they
should be given kudos i guess for that
but what they do with the research is is
equally important and so one of the
things that a lot of independent
researchers who are very qualified want
to do is have more access to facebook
data obviously anonymized but facebook
has been pushing back saying because of
cambridge analytica they're not allowed
to they're not legally so let's make it
legal for facebook to be able to do this
to be able to give this information to
qualified um researchers and have the
federal government run this program like
not interfere with the content because
that's not allowed here in this country
and shouldn't be um but actually help
facilitate the information coming out of
facebook and going to researchers who
can then talk back to facebook about
what they find i think that would be
they could the congress could do that
and make it so facebook is not
doesn't have an excuse not to give it
but given the first reactions of mark
zuckerberg it doesn't look like that
this might happen soon does it yeah no
he was doing you know usually he's on an
apology tour because it's usually a
disastrous thing that's happened whether
it's january 6th or uh you know attacks
in myanmar you really can't say anything
but sorry um but in this case they've
decided i use the word brazen to be very
aggressive if you saw their pr people i
thought they were they they did they
should
they did themselves a disservice and
that's me being nice um they attacked
her um you know as someone who wasn't in
the room you know one one thing i say is
if you work for a sausage factory you
don't have to be in the c-suite to
understand that sausage is terrible or
what's in the sausage everybody within
an organization has some sense of what's
happening there and these researchers um
i think they've treated that facebook
has treated its own researchers badly by
sort of throwing them under the bus they
can try it but boy when you have a bunch
of people internally who are
civic-minded and want to make a great
product i think that's the stupidest
thing you could ever do angering people
who are just trying to do the best
products possible and the most safe
products it just sets off a firestorm
internally
cara i mean all this law which might
help forcing facebook to do what you're
asking for
they obviou obviously were written long
before social media existed so what can
be done that this has changed and maybe
you can talk also a little bit about how
europe could help in that regard of what
the united states could learn from the
european union i just talked to
marguerite wesley
um and we talked a lot about that um
there's a bunch of things she's working
on obviously there's some lawsuits
there's some fines there's some laws
they're trying to pass
europe has always been ahead on this
stuff now some we talked about gdpr
because it hasn't quite worked the way
they wanted because the big companies um
have the lawyers and the ability to
meet the needs of european regulators
and small companies don't there's a
couple things and what's really hard is
to put it into one basket there is no
one basket you could do a transparency
thing around research you could do a
stronger data privacy laws here in this
country we could have justified national
privacy bill we could have an
anti-hacking bill like to be able to
inform people when they've been hacked
you could do anti-trust action around
about mergers and acquisitions you could
do fines you could give the ftc and
other agencies charged with um with
running with monitoring these companies
and regulating them more money and more
staff there's all kinds of bills like
this going on and each of them addresses
a different problem there's no fix-it
solution
for any of them because all of the
companies are also different and you see
with apple
they had a lawsuit um there's some
question of whether there should be some
regulatory approach to app stores that
google and apple control pretty much
apple is taking its own initiative by
doing some things too so if you put
enough pressure on these companies they
will start to put practices in place and
the last thing is liability well two
things taxing them that more for the
data they collect taxing data um and
then lastly liability they don't have
any liability because of section 230 as
well known so is there some way to give
people an ability to sue these companies
that doesn't um completely wreck their
businesses right so everyone else can be
sued you can be excuse me you can be
sued i can be sued um uh you know a
financial firm can be sued uh doctors
can be sued facebook can't be sued so
for the most part um and so why not give
them some liability
and the
alex jones just lost a lawsuit because
of things he said on facebook why can't
facebook why can't those parents do
facebook if they don't win they don't
win but the ability to put pressure on
from from a legal point of view is a
strong one and then lastly changing our
anti-trust laws
sorry
lastly changing our anti-trust laws here
in this country um they're antiquated
and they need to be modernized for the
modern age um and so that's one thing
that needs to happen because no matter
what if the justice department or the
fdc bring cases they're dealing with old
anti-trust laws and judges mostly
conservative here in this country now
are knocking them down and the judges
are correct because that's what the law
says and so um they can't go beyond what
the law says and so changing what
antitrust is has to be done by congress
but exactly congress and given the
really divided political landscape how
likely is it that anything will happen
with these two parties who rather fight
each other than writing fighting for a
good cause well they do agree on this
i'll tell you that it was interesting to
watch marcia blackburn and blumenthal
senator blumenthal richard bloom is all
together you never see them agree on
anything and by the way they do agree
back room right they do on some things
um like senator charles grassley and
senator klobuchar have agreed on a lot
of things um david cicilline in the
house who did an amazing report and ken
buck
very smart now they have some
differences around conservative bias etc
but i think most legislators are on
board with this idea that tech needs
some sort of regulation and we have to
sort it out
um one thing that i think will not pass
and should have has is an idea there's
an idea to create a new um department of
the covers of data
it's been thought about in the past the
united states it is really problematic
um to have the government have any role
in content moderation in this country we
have the first amendment we've got all
kinds of things we should really think
hard about something like that that
could be you know it's not like we
haven't had problems with authoritarians
in this country recently so we do not
want the ministry of information uh that
we do not want that but
we'll see if that's not we're gonna pass
but something like that is problematic
that's resonates very well with our
german audience i'm pretty sure yeah
experienced in both parts of germany
right in the like before uh
before they had the gdr and then the gdr
so yeah canada is passing some very
strict laws that make me nervous i have
to say government should not be involved
in content moderation ever ever
you just mentioned january 6 the
storming of the capital would probably
not have happened without social media
so my question is how urgent is is that
something might change within the united
states
before the next elections and i'm not
talking about the presidential elections
in three years i'm talking about the
midterms they will happen in yeah eighth
of november in one year so a little bit
more than a year
yeah
i think we're worried about violence
here and violence stoked by social media
listen let me just put this to clear one
of the things that facebook was using
defend itself was we didn't start the
fire we didn't start hate well we don't
think you did like come on this is human
beings president trump is much more
culpable and by the way right at the top
of the list so are the people who riot
it like they shouldn't have entered the
capital um etc said you can go down the
line of people who are a couple of fox
news etc etc but social media amplified
and weaponized a lot of this stuff it
didn't make them attack but it didn't
help the matter and in fact it
accelerated it and so what do we do
about that what what what precisely we
do because you do have a fine line of
people being able to say what they want
and have divergent opinions and stuff
it's just blatantly false and defamatory
again why liability is a really
important thing and so that's where i
would say like did you like there's so
many examples of facebook not having
enough staff in other countries where
there was in myanmar et cetera et cetera
there's lots of reporting on this and i
think what's important is to really give
them don't blame them for everything but
give them the blame they deserve and
that's really they're doing a very
tricky thing by saying
you know i'm almost like they're almost
saying like we didn't start the civil
war i'm like part two and i'm like no
but you're not helping it right you're
not you're definitely part of the
problem and not part of the solution
um
when we talk about facebook this week we
also have to talk about the shutdown
president six hours even more maybe
worldwide shutdown of the zuckerberg
empire what should we take from that
well that that these things happen right
technology is not by the way one of the
things that's really remarkable is that
the internet worked really well during
the pandemic boy
did we need it and boy didn't it shut
down so that was a good thing even
though we've had massive hacking et
cetera that's a whole nother sidelight
we need to focus on uh very heavily but
um but you know this is an important
service across the globe people couldn't
do their business
um couldn't share things with their
families this this company has enormous
breadth and power over citizens across
the globe if that doesn't make you
wonder
you're not you're not asking yourself
the right questions why does one person
mark zuckerberg have so much unlimited
power across the globe on how we think
how we speak how we communicate etc i
think he's as i've said i don't think
he's an evil person i think he's a very
nice guy but i you know
i wouldn't put him in charge of all this
therefore we should take the burden off
his
his very uh very thin shoulders
um do you think we will get more
information will there more be leaked
yes yes i think one of the when these it
reminds me a little bit and by the way
i'm not comparing mark zuckerberg to
travis kalanick who i think
behaved much worse than he did um but
when susan fowler wrote that essay that
got so much attention
that started off a big change in uber
now again i was not perfect but that guy
got fired he got moved along i think the
stuff starts to leak out when one person
has the guts to do it and i think
francis haugen yes the guts that have
the guts to do it and articulate it very
beautifully we'll see if there's more
but suddenly it's
when it wasn't possible before and then
you see someone do it and you go huh and
she you know and she did it with a lot
of dignity and grace you start to think
about your own life and i think a lot of
people within these companies are sort
of like do i want to be part of this
just like cigarette manufacturers you
know you had jeffrey wiggin do was it
was it was a leak or a very important
cigarette manufacturing leaker
these
eventually the truth will out eventually
takes a while there's a lot of damage
but eventually that happens
tara thank you so very much thank you
you